the performer has always kept the writer
in his place by reminding him
continually the toughest part of the job
is facing an audience then along come a
couple of writers who could not only
write but can also write songs and
connect and can sing and can appear on
Broadway in their own show and can
incite undying hatred and those of us
who are good for nothing but to
introduce them well all I can say is let
them find a way to get on by themselves
I'm Betty Comden
and I'm Adolph green and I'm Bob Hope
and I wrote their material
men and women who edit the films you see
and your movie theaters are responsible
for saving more performers and more
writers than anyone else in Hollywood
now the nominees for the best
achievement in film editing are Stuart
Gilmore for the Alamo
Daniel Mandel for the apartment
Frederick Newton for inherit the wind
viola Lawrence and al Clark for Pepe
Robert Lawrence for Spartacus
the winner is Betty thank you the winner
is Daniel Mandel the apartment
to those who make this possible I'm very
very grateful thank you